[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition de votre
journal d'information locale nous sommes
le jeudi 17 novembre et voici les titres
en images c'est un vieux serpent de mer
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 à
hauteur de trappes depuis bientôt 30 ans
le début des travaux est annoncé hier
soir un nouveau conseil municipal
extraordinaire sur la question s'est
déroulée dimanche premier tour de la
primaire de la droite et du centre
comment et surtout où voter dans les
yvelines nouveau donneront le mode
d'emploi de ce scrutin la neige n'est
pas pour demain mais le département
anticipées se prépare à réagir le point
sur le dispositif d'ores et déjà en
place ce sera dans cette édition
les enseignants de lycée en zone
prioritaire ont appelé à la grève ce
jeudi 17 novembre à travers la france il
crème la disparition du dispositif il
réclame le maintien des moyens
supplémentaires dont il bénéficie en
cause la réforme entamée par le
gouvernement mais qui n'a concerné
jusqu'à aujourd'hui que les écoles et
les collèges attrape les professeurs du
lycée henri matisse que vous voyez ont
rejoint le collectif touche pas à ma zep
80% du personnel de l'établissement
étaient en grève aujourd'hui on écoute
l'un des professeurs et sept au micro de
camille lambert au manifeste contre une
sortie programmée de notre lycée du
dispositif éducation prioritaire c'est
un dispositif qui nous garantit des
moyens financiers et
matériel plus conséquent que les
établissements classiques voilà c'est
pour alerter sur le fait qu'il faut
pérenniser la situation pour atteindre
les objectifs qui nous sont fixés en
termes de réussite et de citoyenneté
parce que là ce qu'on me disait c'est
quel avenir en veut pour nos enfants
c'est un projet de près de 20 ans qui
pourrait enfin s'accélérer
l'enfouissement partiel de la nationale
10 à hauteur de trappes hier un conseil
municipal extraordinaire s'est réuni
pour voter en faveur de l'engagement
financier à des différentes parties le
coût de ce projet est tout de même
estimé à 95 millions d'euros les détails
avec nikola kirillovitch
1998 2000 16 18 ans 18 ans que le projet
d'enfouissement de la nationale 10
attrapés dans les cartons un enjeu
majeur pour la mairie et qui semble
enfin avancer les élus municipaux ont
validé hier mercredi 16 novembre le
protocole financier entre les différents
partis état région département
agglomération et communes on a fait un
conseil municipal exceptionnel de façon
à être prêt pour le les jours qui
viennent ou normalement avec l'état le
conseil régional le conseil
départemental la communauté
d'agglomération et la ville on doit
signer le contrat de financement qu'on
vient de voter à l'unanimité moins une
voix à ce conseil municipal
selon le pacte financier voté hier le
projet du recouvrement partiel de la n
10 devrait coûter 95,1 millions d'euros
dont 42 à la charge de l'état très
ennemis pour l'agglomération et 2 pour
la commune de trappes une répartition
voté par l'opposition de droite là pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de débat
particulier sur sur ce point là il
pourrait y en avoir plus tard à propos
du projet proprement dit qui nous pose
quelques questions en termes de
désengorgement réel de la ville en
moyenne 80 mille véhicules passent tous
les jours sur la nationale 10 au niveau
de trappes il y a donc urgence pour les
habitants même si le projet présenté
hier ne fait pas l'unanimité 81 90 mille
voitures par jour enfin voitures et
camions puis le bruit la pollution et on
peut pas on peut pas laisser une ville
comme ça on est des gapençais a visionné
ce trafic on est tous d'accord qui a un
problème mais la solution que nous
propose ne nous satisfait pas une
enquête publique est organisée jusqu'au
17 décembre en mairie de trappes les
travaux devraient débuter en
2018 pour une mise en service espérée en
2021 soit 23 ans après le lancement du
projet
nous ouvrons à présent une page
politique dimanche soir les lions
devront livrer le verdict du premier
tour de la primaire de la droite et du
centre la participation va t'elle
dépassé celle de la primaire de la
gauche c'était en 2011 avec plus de deux
millions cinq cent mille votants en
attendant nous faisons le point sur
l'organisation du scrutin dans le
département et blinois avec haussmann
vendeurs des
biens tout d'abord c'est une élection
ouverte à tous mais il ya quand même des
conditions la première il faut être
inscrit sur les listes électorales
depuis le 31 décembre 2015 la deuxième
il faut être muni de sa carte d'identité
et puis le jour j on vous demandera de
signer une charte qui prouve que vous
partagez les valeurs de la droite et du
centre et puis il ya aussi une
contribution de 2 euros
concernant la signature de cette charte
justement l'engagement est anonyme et
côté organisation haussmann le
dispositif est plutôt important dans le
disent dans le département et bien
264 bureaux de vote seront ouvert lors
des deux tours les dimanches 20 et 27
novembre de 8h à 19h et puis près de
1300 militants et ils lui ont mis la
main à la pâte pour cette primaire mais
je vous laisse écouter les propos
d'alain schmitt le président de la
commission départementale d'organisation
de la primaire en milieu rural on
regroupe bien entendu les villages pour
dans un seul et même bureau donc il peut
y avoir quatre cinq villages regroupés
et il y a des affichettes qui seront
installés apposé sur la porte d'entrée
de chacune de ces mairies dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de bureaux de
vote pour que les électeurs puissent le
le savoir facilement
24 c'est le nombre de bureaux de vote
dans chacune des circonscriptions des
yvelines mais il ya des exceptions oui
en effet prenons par exemple la 11e
circonscription elle accueillera 16
bureaux de vote la répartition est la
suivante cinq bureaux de vote elle
encourt 3 à bois d'arcy et à sentir
l'école de à fontenay le fleury et
seulement une attrape la verrière au
mesnil saint denis je vous laisse
écouter bernard décevant délégué à
l'organisation de la primaire dans la
11e circonscription
si je pense attraper la verrière qui
vote plutôt plus à gauche que qu'une
commune comme il en cours ou fontenay ou
bonnart 6 par exemple mais si je prends
le mesnil s'est tout simplement lié à la
taille de la commune
si vous souhaitez obtenir plus
d'information sur la primaire n'hésitez
pas à vous rendre sur le site primaire
2016 point org ou contacter le 0 821 va
merci haussmann et du côté des du coût
du soutien au pardon des politiques en
coulisses les rangs qui se resserre
autour de chacun des candidats et karl
olive le maire de poissy conseiller
départemental vient ainsi de publier une
tribune en faveur d'alain juppé une
tribune cosignée par 83 élus du
département parmi lesquels le député
maire de versailles françois de mazières
tribune qui se conclut ainsi alain juppé
a besoin d'une victoire franche qui fera
taire les partisans de la division ce
soir se déroulera également le dernier
débat entre les candidats à l'ambiance
devrait être particulièrement électrique
entre les candidats mais aussi avec les
journalistes présents hier soir jean
frédéric poisson elle n'a pas manqué de
faire part de son agacement il déplore
les thématiques abordées et le
traitement qui lui est réservé écoutez
c'était sur le plateau de nos confrères
de france 3 hier soir donc demain soir
dernier débat dans quel état d'esprit
vous l'abordez
monsieur je vais
déroger à une des règles que je me suis
dit que c'est jusqu'ici dans mes
relations avec la presse je ne vais pas
répondre à vos questions et pourquoi
parce que le traitement qui m'a été
infligées depuis le début de la campagne
par france 2 et france 3 est indigne
parce que vous avez reçus sur ces deux
chaînes de télévision pendant des durées
très longues mais concurrents vous savez
quand vous avez ce soir jusqu'ici que
jusqu'ici ce que vous savez que on peut
que j arrete interviewe estime jusqu'ici
bon ceci si vous ne répondez pas aux
questions donc écouté puisque
visiblement vous n'avez pas l'intention
d'écouter ce que j'avais dit que vous je
dis tu fais plateau messieurs je vous
remercie de votre invitation 6 janvier
nous avons bien sûr merci c'est ce qu'on
appelle faire du buzz à pas cher merci
beaucoup le ton est donc donné pour ce
dernier débat prévu jeudi soir et
diffusé notamment sur france télévisions
politique toujours et les réactions à la
candidature d'emmanuel macron à présent
les ténors de notre département de notre
région n'ont pas manqué de commenter l
annonce faite par l'ancien ministre de
françois hollande écoutez tout d'abord à
valérie pécresse la présidente de l'île
de france puis benoît hamon député
socialiste est lui même candidat à la
primaire de la gauche
oh vous savez emmanuel macron pour nous
c'est l'avatar de françois hollande
c'est le coauteur du projet économique
de françois hollande le coresponsable du
matraquage fiscal etc l'auteur de
réformes minuscule sur les magasins le
dimanche et les autocars donc pour
l'instant emmanuel macron pour nous
c'est vraiment la gauche quand on se dit
hors système via des tests assez facile
à faire magnol macro il a une compagne
apparemment très riches liés à des dons
nombreux oui je lui propose de répondre
à la question suivante
située hors système acceptes tu de
rendre public et transparent
les donateurs à très content le syndicat
cfe cgc organisée ce jeudi à 17 novembre
un colloque sur le burn out cette
maladie professionnelle des cuisines en
au travail qui touche une partie
importante de population mais
partiellement reconnu par le code du
travail nicolas dandrieu
fatigue importante perte de connaissance
difficultés pour parler voilà des
symptômes physiques et psychologiques
dans une situation de burn out j'ai
rencontré un cas d'une salariée qui a dû
réapprendre à lire a écrit qu à écrire
tellement ses neurones avaient été
détruits parle parle uggla cortisol qui
est un produit qui a produit qui est
générée par le stress it is détruit les
neurones dans les yvelines le phénomène
est en nette augmentation ce sont les
chiffres qui ont été avancés par une des
intervenantes de la maison souffrance au
travail qui est un stade akwa si la
première année de création en 2013 ils
ont eu 800 personnes deuxième année 3000
personnes sont venus les voir et la
quatrième la troisième année par non
onze mille personnes sont venus les voir
à 54 ans daniel le meunier travail dans
une multinationale après une
restructuration elle est contrainte
d'occuper le poste de chargé de voyages
problème elle n'avait pas les
compétences pour cet emploi et a subi
une surcharge de travail
je m'étais dit tant pis parce que j'ai
pas le choix l'entreprise je l'aimais et
j'ai envie de donner encore et de
prouver que je peux faire encore autre
chose de nouveau et et ça n'a pas fait
parce que j'avais perdu le sommeil parce
que j'avais perdu l'appétit parce que
j'avais perdu confiance en moi confiance
en
entreprise je suis certainement bernal
tekkari vais parce qu'il y avait cette
surcharge de travail
daniel a été arrêté en mai 2014 mon
système nerveux et a été impactée est
abîmée j'ai un traitement lourd l'eau et
je sais que je vais pas retrouvé ma
santé je sais et
mes jeux
je chope ça c'est important pour moi
c'est ma thérapie c'est mieux qu'un
médicament
engagement important dans son emploi
difficultés économiques de l'entreprise
et le travail à la maison les causes du
burn out sont multi ce sujet pourrait
émerger dans les débats politiques
comme chaque année le département des
yvelines se prépare pour réagir à
d'éventuelles intempéries cet hiver en
cas de neige ou de verglas c'est
sableuse ont donc intervenir pour à
déblayer les routes du département
explications avec anne-laure languit sur
des images du but une première le
commentaire de michael et demi d'euros
voilà le scellé le véhicule de
déneigement du 14 novembre 13 mars 2017
le département mobilise des effectifs
supplémentaires pour assurer aux usagers
des conditions de circulation fluide on
renforce l'astreinte c'est à dire qu'en
fait on va voir 37 agents qui sont
d'astreinte 24 heures sur 24 pour
éventuellement intervenir ou sur sur les
routes des yvelines en cas de phénomènes
qui pourraient être potentiellement
bisang stockés dans différents entrepôts
ce sont au total trois mille huit cent
cinquante tonnes de sel qui sont
accessibles aux agents des montagnes
prête à être dispersés pour éviter tout
accident de la route les interventions
restent cependant rares si je prends
l'exemple de l'an dernier n'est sorti je
crois 144 fois et c'était 5 fois
seulement curatif donc ça veut dire que
ça explose 135 x en préventif le bol et
à des 1400 km de routes départementales
ne dépend pas seulement de la réactivité
des agents publics mais aussi du bon
sens des usagers soyons vigilants et
lyon les bons réflexes si on me dit que
les conditions risquent d'être mauvaise
eh bien je me renseigne bien avant de
tenter quoi que ce soit parce que si
vous vous retrouvez sur une route dans
laquelle vous ne pouvaient plus circuler
parce que les conditions sont
impraticables
eh bien vous créer des désordres vous
créez les embouteillages voir des
accrochages et surtout les saleuses ne
peuvent plus passer pour éviter les
embouteillages veillez donc à ne pas
vous engager sur les routes si les
chutes de neige sont trop importantes et
à ne pas gêner l'action des sableuses
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi la rédaction vous donne
rendez vous demain vendredi à partir de
18h pour le 7-8 hebdo nicolas
kirillovitch qui recevra guy malandain
le maire socialiste de trappes très
bonne soirée
[Musique]